kind of cool that we get to make a movie
it's kind of really really crazy that we
get to make a movie i kind of have to
pinch myself every day do you need one
now yeah can you would you real is it i
don't know
i'm bruce kaufman and i play lenny
walker and my name is jacques coleman i
play joe fontaine
can i ask you a question
please please do what'd you do when you
found out you got the role
i just felt the most honor that i was
chosen to play a role that meant so much
to me and then i started crying
like ugly crying like ugly crying like
the ugliest thing it gets
you like lenny i like her a lot
i really love her passion for things you
think you'd be friends with her in real
life i think so as somebody who has had
their fair share of grief and coming to
terms with loss we would get along
because there was a mutual understanding
there
it's really beautiful oh thanks i've
said too much
lenny has trepidation with playing
clarinet right yeah especially after she
loses bailey she finds it really hard to
pursue the things that she's passionate
about it's really challenging for her to
find that momentum to play clarinet how
she used to
karna is a part instrument lenny blows
my mind how she's able to play
something that's so challenging so
flawlessly but you do it too yeah but i
had to learn clarinet for this role i
thought you told me that you were
playing clarinet for like 10 years oh uh
is that
what i said
look at this
are you excited to get out of these
woods i mean who wouldn't these trees
are like over a thousand years old and
we're so lucky we just get the frolic in
this that's like basically what we get
to do
it's like the trees are talking
what are they saying to you
look at me be all beautiful in the wind
and shiny and
green
what's your favorite moment on set
individually with each person i've had
such heartfelt and hilarious
moments it's been really special
[Music]
you